how's it going red my name is beautiful
thank heaven that I survived that last
thing look at my oh no no no bad baby
sad baby baby to Justin Bieber's demon
sponge
[ __ ] ah yeah [ __ ] that's fried you
better keep right now don't come back
[ __ ] don't eat in my face
Julie oh well you know what I have this
the ultimate B will destroy you mm all
right ultimate baby bear insert all
right
chimera high jump oka our [ __ ] doesn't
worry does it okay fine it's chop next
time I teach you [ __ ] hi hi hi
how you then chop me frighten your
peasant come on chop these I can you're
failing companies right in your prison
chubby [ __ ] - baby three baby oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't keep that on me [ __ ] don't
snap on me so - flat on my pendant
that's how I roll look at my health my
health isn't good at Japanese you ain't
catch if you meet me on the street with
a knife I would slice your [ __ ] face
down good that's how I roll Papa guitar
today
oh no nevermind but what am I going stop
playing around with a knife dude stop
playing around
what the hell shut up shut up I speak
Japanese
before you ass down I do I don't need
help
bow out no don't don't do it don't do it
baby
don't do it be there
oh snap or a rapper dapper that's how we
do it in my hometown [ __ ]
stop playing with night okay don't
really remember I guess over here a hole
in the wall a hole in the wall huh let's
take the I think I can't no I can't come
from there or dead yeah I did I did did
not but now we have chopped nice now
PewDiePie is really confused that's okay
[ __ ] okay this is where the batteries
were and now that little [ __ ] will come
from here I think yep yeah hey well just
expect the thing Hey yes I will I know
chop knife before you're a dumb bunny
Stephanie Stuart Stephanie who stabbed
it a Steve seven star 74 on your
necklace girl aren't you on don't give
yourself a bj stop don't get more in
there you're supposed to stop stop
sucking your dick [ __ ] what fine stop
that cool this is how I want to go when
I die oh no I'm dying no that's funny
okay good I can't go in there we can't
go in here no no Baba dabba doo stop are
you gonna be like a brother
Japanese in-your-face Japanese and
nipples ow
shut up so [ __ ] creepy shut up Oh
fine fine
see if I care let's watch Peter fine I'm
in town hey come and me breath alright
shut slap slap
chop chop chop chop chop chop
you can't hit me stop giving yourself a
bj what the [ __ ] stereo BJ [ __ ] porno
people really there was no point of this
room
glad I wasted the time
glad I have my time wasting what is
there a sweater they're going in here
and going in day I don't even see what's
going up and down turn it out no no no
no now nut stop how am I supposed tell
you I don't have much help no no no no
no no no not today sorry not today
period comes from the Medina not the
face okay fine oh my god
Oh what in the hell oh [ __ ] the period
people
oh you that's looking good for you
how about right here okay good Ronna
what what am I supposed to do here I'm
not going in there all batteries and
Michelle come on dude
don't come in here I can't shoot him
what am i I know now the period man is
odd me okay Jared man is coming I hate
her I hate occasion I can trade the pay
what was that I saw two feet there no
it's in the know that was an MLG [ __ ]
right there holy Sh did you see that I
just went around and I just chopped
chopped and I all right I want to give
myself an Oscar or Nobel Prize finally I
can creat clear that surface
my father was merely a topic of
discussion between myself and my mother
I was reserved in the phone with
hospital documents my path became player
for the first time and it seems like
years I made my way Kelly to the
hospital in search of records of files
on my father
I rather family members who might
haven't been admitted the family history
has become one of the utmost important
to me sometimes it's better to run and
avoid an enemy haha that was the tip
sometimes better to run
oh hell [ __ ] it's a SAN so we're going
through my dead dad
okay con no okay
one look at my my money in here
somewhere
look at that alright so I'm no no no no
no no no not today sir not today sir not
today not today sir not today sir
tonight - oh snap
well you ain't gonna give yourself a bj
not on my watch
not on my [ __ ] stop stab yourself in
the back
wait a second are they killing
themselves to make me think that I am
killing them 9fuc would make sense
nah quick say yes think I'm so happy I
found batteries all the [ __ ] time
because I don't need health or ammo or
anything like that no thank-you games
there's a funky pan okay fine
good Sam leave that [ __ ] chop nice
though
all right what do you want all right
guys
third floor [ __ ] ah door [ __ ] out
what is this good paintings good time
good time good time good time good time
get out of my way box first aid well it
sure is how it came here one of that
[ __ ] uh exam room all right how's it
going in here
Alice Kelly that's been a good why do I
hear sound I don't like this I don't
like when things draw attention what is
this about my name is Pierce and I speak
Japanese so freaking alright meeting
room
storia maybe we can find some health
back no really I put a [ __ ] stereo
but no health packs we're at the
hospital for crying out loud that's
you're locked
well here's first floor and here goes
nothing it's gonna be enemies we're just
alone my pretzel oh come on why do you
got to do that you know I'm gonna kill
you stop kill me why do you do that why
do you do this disgrace it's not natural
thank you stop sucking your own day
not I wish I could fly like that oh no I
don't
Oh - what was well that is a problem if
this [ __ ] box ah [ __ ] two of them all
right black ones first because that's
not racist I killed your brother
yeah I killed him with my flash I want
to eat your pet because you're not sure
that's how I roll
that's how I get on in it stop sucking
damage why do they keep doing it
I'll let me know I'll never know
pharmacy ah police I'm going it's gonna
be health packs and you know what soon
if I find a health bag I'm not even
gonna pick it up because I need a
padlock here all right I don't see a
code or anything lovely house look at
those sheep sick making out that cheep
cheeps are not supposed to make out with
each other but it's a rim oh that's
lovely what it a magazine thank you all
it's quite quite lovely
all right maybe this thing I just like
don't even worry about it
thank you Jesus
holy [ __ ] those were annoying okay what
do we got
all right we got a shower I'm paying a
little bit it's gotta be a clue here oh
there it is
no and then sing there is absolutely
nothing in here they were just having
wild dog showers sex that's good well
there's gotta be a code written down
somewhere finally I found it four nine
eight two three four nine eight two
three four nine eight two three four
nine eight two three [ __ ] four nine
eight two three all right girl
alright girl okay I can do this out or
enjoy a chose access granted my god no
no no no no God son of AB I hate those I
hate those what do I do whatever I do
whatever they're okay okay okay come
here
pop in the habit a habit of here happy
to have it at I hate those [ __ ]
[ __ ] get in and close the door close
the door close the door close the door
close the door
[ __ ] you does he have a [ __ ] sister
ah night sky over another but wearing
this think big
bigger than the all the other things I
don't know I don't know
wait a minute wait a minute I said tell
me what you see ah right two ears and a
head